[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
fourth episode of my love and Tulsa
cylindric Ruta from the black
perspective in this episode I am going
to cover eight Quinton a three moon in
detail which arises after the following
order Evo c5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d
4c captures d4 Knight captures default
Aoife high night to be Phi a six Knight
to d6 Czech Bishop captures d6 Queen
captures d6 Queen to f6 attacking the
Queen and white plays this second least
popular choice namely Queen to b3 so as
you can see I have highlighted a very
simple plan by white he wants to quickly
take out his Queen side piece and Castle
queenside meantime this Queen is well
placed and controlling black castle on
the Kings side well against this I must
tell that black has to play
energetically otherwise if you continue
with slow moves then your position
becomes worse very quickly the first
move I think you already know apart from
Queen to d1 as I mentioned in my earlier
video the universal Lewis Knight G to e7
looking at defy break so indeed if white
continue with slow moves such as Bishop
to b3 or Bishop to d3 then we will go
ahead and play the move defy and from
the past two videos we already see the
consequences how good black position can
become so indeed white needs to stop it
with Knight to c3 which in fact played
in almost all the games okay now comes a
very important moment of this video and
I think if you remember blacks next move
which is very important in this
variation
then you won't have any trouble in this
line here comes the first memory marker
guys and please remember this very
cunning move rook to b8 which gives
black a very active game so as you can
see Black has a simple plan to grab
space on the Queen side with b v e4
which completely refute white's
queenside castling idea well as for the
database Bishop to e3 is a most popular
choice however let's see other sideline
moves such as what to do against Knight
to d5 well generally speaking whenever
the knight appears on d5 we are going to
chop it off and after pawn captures defy
here you can play Knight to d4 but I
think Bishop to d3 refused all the
threats so accordingly black should
continue his knight to e7 attacking one
defy if d6 the knight to a fire is a
very strong reply and in a long run
white get a huge problem to defend the
d6 pawn so accordingly white needs to
defend the d5 pawn well logically
speaking there are two ways we can
defend the pawn but amongst them one is
completely wrong Bishop to c4 bad move
and the simple refutation goes as
follows defy attacking the bishop Bishop
to b3 and now the very simple move
Bishop to b7 attacking to soft spot
which white cannot defend both of them
and hang on if you think that d6 is
working think twice because after Knight
to a5 black instantly getting winning
position
so it is very obvious that here white
has to continue with c4 in order to
safeguard the defy born well now we are
going to follow a game between two
masters and I think this game is a model
demonstration how easily black get upper
hand in just within few moves the first
obvious move d6 not only stopping future
advancement of C Phi by black also
liberate this light square bishop and
night to d4 is in the agenda white
continues where naturally with Bishop to
e2 planning to castle on the Kings side
and after the move Knight to a5 I think
if white continue with castle on the
Kings side the knight to d4 is quite
annoying followed by Bishop to a5 which
gives black a very good game so
accordingly in the game white stop this
idea by playing Bishop to e3 so at first
sight this position looks quite innocent
right there is nothing going on in this
position and it seems like white is
slightly better due to his space
advantage but just look at few moves
Knight --which for attacking on G to
White Castle on the King side and after
the move Queen to g6 I think position is
completely gone for the white camp yep
you heard it right first of all he
cannot play Bishop to have three as
Knight captors f3 and white loses a
piece so in the game in order to save
the made white play the move g3 which
even doesn't turn out well as after the
simple continuation Bishop twedge 3
attacking the rook
unfortunately that rook cannot move why
well let's see what's the reason so
let's say white continued it rook to c1
then we have this little move
quint we for once again creating a
checkmate threat and after the only
sequence f3 Knight captures f3 Czech
Bishop captures f3 and Queen captures f3
not only the mating thread remain as it
is but in this position black is a clear
upon up and with some accurate play this
should be converted into the full point
in the game obviously master saw it so
he continued with f4 and his opponent
responded with evil but I think it's a
great deal of inaccuracy as here black
should not make it complicated and take
the rook on f1 because after Bishop
captures f-fun rook captures have fun
and the movie foe just within 18 moves
black obtained an exchange and I don't
think so there is any compensation for
the white camp
so I think night to defer is premature
at this position and that's why the
correct main line start with Bishop to
e3 to whom which we are going to
continue with our thematic expansion b5
already threatening befall and nab piece
that means white is forced to move
either of this piece there are two
popular choices here namely Queen to b3
and Knight to d5
however if your opponent continued with
passive moves such as Knight to e2 then
you already see that white has lost the
control on the D Phi Square and that's
where our traumatic break comes into the
picture yup the golden break D Phi
happens
and after a takes d5 Knight takes d5
black position already looks quite
decisive okay let's check out what
happens after white continue with two
different main lines the first move I
want to consider is Queen to b3 which
personally I don't like it as simply
white has given up to pressurise black
camped on the Kings side and accordingly
Knight to d4 is a fitting reply so as
you can see white has no option but to
take this night and after pawn takes
Knight to d5 and after Knight takes d5
position looks quite comfortable for the
black camp white has to already be
careful as he cannot capture with the
EEP on the simple reason is after castle
on the King side threatening rook - eh
egg so white responds his force white
has to castle on the Queen side but the
net result is after Queen captures f2
black emerge with extra pawn and already
pressure going on on the Queen side
so that means he kept his defy at this
point is right out of the equation why
it has to capture back with the Queen
but see the pressure black is building
up in this line with Bishop to b7
attacking the Queen and Queen has only
space to go fi if she goes to somewhere
else
for example Queen to c5 which looks very
obvious stopping black to castle on the
Kings side but after just one move rook
to c8 Queen to a3 and rook captures c2
wide get a completely losing position
okay so that means Queen to a5 forced
and after that my recommendation is you
should avoid the Queen exchange and
continue with Queen to e7
if white castle on the coincide then
we'll definitely take the he for point
with our Bishop so that's why one of the
game in the database continued with
Bishop to d3 defending on e4
but now comes the second important
memory marker in this line namely Queen
to b4 check well it is very obvious that
if white moves the king then we are
going to castle on the Kings side so
accordingly the only response here is c3
black cannot take on b2 as after Queen
to if I tagged black instantly get
losing position so please don't fall for
this the big idea is we have provoked
the c3 move and now we are coming back
to e7 which surprisingly enough very
strong continuation in this line why it
certainly cannot take on d4 as after
Queen to b4 check King to e2 and Queen
captures d4 White's King is stuck in the
center and black is building up some
good thread so obviously that's not a
choice for the white camp and
accordingly Castle has to be played in
this position well after that now you
see the importance of Queen check
because black and take on c3 and after
pawn takes c3 and the moon castle on the
Kings side yes indeed black has a
weakness on the d7 square but on the
counterpart White has two weaknesses and
as the game progressed you are going to
see how easily black and target those
things in the game white continue with
rook a to c1 so his idea is very simple
he wants to get rid of this weakness but
guess what black doesn't even give time
for that rook to yet happen pressurizing
the e4 pawn white played f3 completely
neutralizing that bishop but doing so
what he forgot is black and now play
this Tim Maki break defy hand
of factories it is black who is able to
get rid of his weakness obviously white
cannot take that pawn and I think you
have seen it right what happens after he
captures defy well very simple white is
going to lose a piece after Queen check
King 2h funny and now g6 driving that
Queen away from the bishop and winning
the game on the spot so that's not a
possibility for the white cam so in the
game
white continue with Bishop to b1 which
even doesn't turn out well as after pawn
takes Bishop takes Bishop takes pawn
takes if you see the position right now
black has impact pawn structure where
look at the Queen side of the white it
has some horrible fractured bone which
in fact become a clear-cut target in the
endgame and indeed black managed to win
the game in a style last but not least
what happens if white continue with
Knight to d5 which is in fact one of the
main line in this position and we
already know what to do against Knight
to d5 yup
Knight captures d5 pawn captures d5 and
Knight to e7 attacking on loose D Phi
Square
well if c4 then d6 is a very strong
reply so accordingly the mainline
continue with castle on the Queen side
and here I'm going to introduce one of
my own novelty in this line
well the online start with d6 with
stopping Bishop to c5 by white but I
think that line is problematic as white
get some good attack on the black king
so instead of that my recommendation is
you should continue with Bishop to b7
attacking on defy one thing you have to
always remember that whenever I play the
move d6 it's a bad choice for the white
cam as after Knight to f5 not only that
pawn can become a target later on but
that allows black to castle on the Kings
side so d6 is a big-time positional
blunder and if I play the move f4 which
happens in few games then I think black
should respond with E 4 and the pressure
on defy remain intact so considering all
this the best choice for the white is to
play the move Bishop to c5 and
sacrificing the d5 pawn which in fact
happen in three games and the result is
not so great for the black game and I
can understand that as in all the three
games black took the pawn and his King
stuck in the center so now it is stun
for minority and my recommendation is
you should continue with rook to d8
which in fact never happened in any of
the feeder games so as you can see the
idea is very simple black wants to play
d6 and consolidate his position and if
white continue with d6 then apart from
Knight to a5 black has the move Knight
to g6 activate the Black Knight
so once again white is forced to play
this moon namely Bishop to d6 stopping
black to castle on the Kings side and
against this we should continue with
Knight to f5 attacking the bishop white
Bishop has to go to the c7 has instead
of this white continue to put his Bishop
on a long diagonal with let's say Bishop
to b4 then white get a very active
position faith d6 in fact I have reached
this position in one of my blitz game
where my opponent continue with g4 which
looks very aggressive on the King side
but this move doesn't turn out well as
after Knight to default pressurizing the
d5 pawn my opponent defended with Bishop
to g2 but after just one move Queen
captures f2 white position Parrish very
quickly
okay so Bishop to c7 what else and after
that our response is force we have to
attack this Bishop and if Bishop to a5
then Knight to e7 is a very strong reply
so the main point about this variation
is white wants to play d6 and completely
jam up blacks Quinn side well yes indeed
you can castle at this point but here
comes the third important memory marker
give the priority to this important
maneuver Knight to d4 so no matter
whatever white plays next we want to do
is Knight to e6 and dislodge that bishop
and if you can do that then black get a
very aggressive game now to illustrate
the danger in this position I like to
show you one of my game against a 2288
opponent where my opponent continued
with King to be one I responded
obviously with Knight to e6 attacking
the bishop Bishop to b6 of this response
defending on f2 and now the trademark
law in Thal sicilian moon comes with a
tempo Queen to g6 see to his hanging if
white defend with the rook then Bishop
to e4 is a very strong reply so
accordingly in the game white continue
with Bishop to d3 counter attacking my
queen I simply capture on g2 and the
good point about Knight to e6 can be
revealed
it is supporting on g7 so white can't
even take back his phone
well in the game white was afraid of
Luke s 2g1 as his h2 pond was hanging so
he continued with rook D to G 1 which is
a big time mistake and before I reveal
the final few moves kindly pause the
video and find out the finishing knot
are you ready let's start the first boy
is very obvious Queen to c6
attacking the bishop and it doesn't
matter wherever this bishop moves let's
say Bishop to b5 after blacks next reply
my opponent simply resign and the move
is very cute Evo and that Bishop no
matter wherever it goes it will be lost
the most amazing thing I found about
this game is look at my Queen move first
it goes to g6 then g2 then c6 and then
deliver the deciding blow on CT
that's it guys
I am sure now that after watching this
video you are very confident to face the
Moon Queen to e3 only thing you have to
remember in this line is after the move
Knight to c3 play this trademark moon
rook to b8 and once your pressure is
going on on the Queen side white cannot
develop naturally there and black get
good position in almost all the lines
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
you